we have your own music heaven oh yeah
it's like a whole new Sabrina yeah so
tell me what that was like is there a
little bit of apprehension our nerves
putting this new sound out there for
fans and wondering how they're going to
react to it I guess it starts when you
get very close to releasing it
so I'm three days away at this point and
I do feel like I'm starting to like you
know not question but you do go wow I
guess to me this doesn't feel like a
different sound because it's it's
happened so naturally and the
progression was so I didn't really think
about it too much it just kind of I did
what I felt but now starting to release
some of these songs and seeing the
reaction seeing that people do think it
is so different um is also really cool
and and shows me that it's exactly what
I wanted to do I don't usually want to
do the same thing twice or three times I
would get very bored so I'm excited for
everyone to hear it how would you say it
is different sonically thematically I
think you grow so much in these years
you know these young adult years or
you're coming into your own and
everything you're writing about most of
it you're experiencing for the first
time so it's it's like you're really
ripping off a band-aid
and everything feels so fresh and
everything feels so exciting or I feel
so painful and that makes it more I
don't know emotional so I think I think
a lot of it is just me coming into my
own and finding my own sandwich what
makes it sound so different than
anything I've done before
two years of a bunch of writing
workshops has 60 songs that you had yeah
over 60 at this point so is there
pressure to have a see a commercial
success considering how much time you've
invested in this project you can't
really look at it like that because for
me like I I just have to look at music
as and I'm doing what I love and if I
ever stop thinking about it like that it
starts to become something different and
of course it's it's super easy to get
caught up in it and think about all that
but at the end of the day I have this
really incredibly supportive fanbase
that has followed me and like you said
like I have changed a lot through my
music so the fact that they are still
SRS all dog they are so so so loving and
supportive with each release and are
growing with me in a sense because I
think they are kind of figuring out what
they like at the same time as I am
figuring out what I like and it's just
this beautiful relationship so that's
that's all I care about at the end of
the day is is them and you know
hopefully helping them get through life
a little bit easier what do you say
helps keep you grounded in this
good people people that have your best
interests at heart and and people that
want to see you succeed and that believe
in you and it's hard to find them so
when you when you do have them you just
hold on to them really close but I think
that the other thing that keeps you
grounded is really reminding yourself
while you do it in the first place is
reminding yourself like oh when I was
seven years old I love to sing I love to
sing songs by my favorite artist and
then the fact that I got to grow up and
sing my own songs and learn how to write
my own songs and you know be in
different films and movies that I care
about films and movies are kind of the
same thing but I guess not to some
people and TV shows that I care about
that's crazy
you know and it's so easy to to not
think about it like that most the time
when you're so zoomed in on your own
life that's a good question a lot of the
songwriters and producers that I work
with are super honest and I think that I
feel like that has been such a safe
space for me and probably why the sound
is so different because I in an
environment where I wasn't surrounded by
the people's opinions that I I do like
listened to a lot like my family and my
friends they're not there when I'm when
I'm creating these songs and these
songwriters and producers have become
some of my closest friends but in the
beginning when you're getting to know
people it's sort of like well I guess
you don't really know anything about me
you don't really know where I've been
and so you kind of get to know each
other by going right to the gritty stuff
and that creates a different
relationship than I have with you know
my friends and family so yeah
so we my team yes so you think about
love heartbreak sex and you've lived a
huge chunk of your life in the public
eye since of the age of 30 area what's
the best rumor misconception that you've
heard about yourself would you say
during that time you hear a lot wow
that's so hard I don't know if I mean
the rumors definitely not that I'm
taller in person so I don't know exactly
I think a misconception for a lot of
people is just that you know it's very
easy to think that because I started in
one place I became a singer because of
that whereas I I just I started posting
covers on YouTube when I was nine so
music was really what came first for me
and and song right it was something that
I started to do when I was 10 years old
I think I didn't get good at it and so
later and I still don't think I'm you
know I still always think I'll have room
to learn and room to grow but I think
that would be a misconception is a lot
of people think that it was acting first
but it was actually music